and Kirsten as the excitement builds
in-home hockey courts are now in demand
all across the valley eight news now
reporter Mary Jane ballessa shares the
sport courts inspired by the team
for eight-year-old Max Moody playing
hockey is one of his favorite sports and
having a roller hockey Court in his
backyard has made it that much easier to
play with friends and get behind his
favorite team the Vegas golden knights
it's pretty awesome we will try to get
this miles Reynolds is the owner of
Sport Court Las Vegas he installed this
court for Max's family ever since the
knights have come here to Vegas so we've
been been doing you know building more
and more because they're great for
inline skates and safety is a huge thing
too so if they you know if the kids are
skidding out they're not getting hurt
either he's seen the need grow after the
team first started and has gotten
requests to get the Vegas golden knights
logo on other courts he's built we
probably have about 30 courts you know
and there's definitely been a huge
uptick ever since the knights came as
far as requests because it's it's not
you know it's a sport that's on
everybody's radar these kids emulate you
know emulate all these players we've
actually been able to even build some of
the the courts for the actual Knights
players like pacharetti and Marsha Saul
it's great to have a court you know as
far as the customization though to have
an actual like Knights logo in your
backyard is pretty makes kids feel like
they have a you know a stadium right in
their backyard courts like these are
custom made which can take up to four to
six weeks with construction taking up to
one to two weeks Max and his friends are
hoping for a big victory tonight I
really hope we win it's gonna be
frustrating if we don't win